guys we did it after 10 years I am
finally taking break this is the last
video no I'm not quitting media as much
as you want it but this is my final
video and of course it's why leave your
[Music]
I can't believe this is so strange
I'm savoring every moment truth is I
don't want to go and break truth is I
love making videos I just feel like I
need to do this I need to do this so one
life slow lying oh this is my favorite
kind of videos because it's the videos
where I get to interact with you guys
and it's not completely annoying i watch
my dog chases tail for 10 minutes and
thought wow dogs are so easily
entertained then I realized I just watch
my dog chases tail for 10 minutes that's
a very small brain and a very small
peepee oh god this is the last time I'll
ever judge a PB this one is for debate
this one is for ideas this one is for
opinions and this one
it's a fact and that's a fact big peepee
absolutely when all people want is a low
brightness meme that doesn't hurt your
eyes stunk big peepee this is a blessed
peepee you know what since I'm leaving
I'm gonna change it everything is big
peepee today today's big peepee day
Finland who plans hundred and fifty
million trees a year team tree planting
20 million trees
shut up Finland no one cares still big
peepee though still big peepee I'll
drink to some big BP virus your computer
you free antivirus software Jabra big
beefy friend meet big beefy friend
hey you're me Mozilla why me yeah but he
didn't give me a PP rating oh my god I
am so sorry friend why is that important
me it defines Who I am
you get a big peepee you get a big
peepee you all get big peepee today's
special day
there it is I've been working on
PewDiePie action game for almost a year
damn alright big peepee I did play in
very big peepee me murders an entire
village and sets everything on fire
minecraft I understand because I am
minecraft veteran yes yeah would you all
still eat this my name is Chloe I wanted
to live your personal choice killed me
don't buy it don't buy it don't try it
Anakin I would look for one with my name
on it
I don't want a big peepee but I have to
Oh God
Oh word pute change Lawai two people
review his subreddit dick pic appearance
that's literally my faves if that
happens my god you guys know me too well
it's like we need a break or something
it's all it's getting creepy made this
before I get drafted hope this gets me
in pee-peed gang okay that's a P and I
want it good focusing come on you can do
it you can focus the camera no we can
all right I actually wanted to give that
small people just for the blur but it's
big P P day you're a friendly neighbor
Iranian gamer I just want peds and
everyone this sub to know that there's a
lot of Iranian 90 miles and we don't
want to go with the war with fellow
sincerely an Iranian 90 or literally we
just need to like PP it out you know
what I mean you can just do a real life
fortnight event doesn't stand that's all
you need if you actually think World War
3 is still gonna happen at this point I
I Got News for you you can [ __ ] it I
can say the R word because I'm going on
break this feels great what else can I
say
Australia pray for Australian big peepee
have you seen
videos were koalas are so thirsty I feel
so terrible go donate you know I made a
generous donation streaming while sick
and donating $10 to app Australia to
Africa and Australia every time I cough
big VP all around well done lad well
done women have to deal with cramps but
what do men have to deal with big people
- both of you - everyone I feel such
great sense of euphoria equanimity I
feel so good since Puetz doesn't play
minecraft as much anymore
he should upload it save file and host
the competition where we get to edit it
and then review some of them after a
couple weeks just like good ol days with
Lawai that's perfect cuz I'm going away
anyway I'll pass on the torch to you
guys you guys take over bro time it's
the only way the only way to pass on the
torch I've been doing this for too long
why is this episode so sad I've been
doing it daily for so long what am I
gonna do
glad I got it though I don't work ahead
either so even if it seems like I'm away
I'm never really away you know what I
mean
I'm always there Google don't suicide
yourself guys you'll die Bing dying is
bad and all but at least he makes things
more interesting wait I actually said
that
what the [ __ ] context was behind that
feelings so I'm trying to make it harder
for myself but I think what I meant to
say was war is bad and all I think more
is don't listen to bang
don't listen to Bing you can tell my
Asia Said's catching up with me guys
dying makes life really interesting if
you would live forever
where's the motivation to do anything
learning instruments you can do that in
500 600 years or so continuing to do
nothing instead you have only a few
decades time to do the things you want
before you die and make them matter this
time the better answer well hot diggity
damn that's some big peepee brain right
there big creepy brain yeah it's a thing
how we see PewDiePie how pretty pie sees
us I I do have a camera I don't have a
webcam I know that's a surprise
I can't tell if trolling or just
incredibly dumb but still big PP well
done
so me and my professor have a tradition
to draw each other's memes on the exams
when the teacher gives you an extra
point for drawing a me stalks when you
are a teacher and you have the power to
decide whether to give an extra point or
not reality
- can't be whatever I want he got an
extra point that's crazy
writing an essay intro in first
paragraph second and third paragraph
conclusion it didn't make me laugh but
big B P that's just how it is
hey they got mr. B's in there very nice
god damn the trio is complete my god
swen waiting for pills - oh God now I
feel terrible I will still play
Minecraft on my spare time of course of
course I would never leave Spanish man
my main it's penny penny penny penny you
know what I mean no way no freakin way
girls post a picture on Instagram
defense okay since I'm gone and maybe I
should shout out a couple channels no
wait that's a terrible idea
well Norwich City did a great video on
low like puns I'll link it in the
description very epic he could be a
nasty but I'm I'm willing to take the
chance my Instagram got deactivated my
family disowned me and the guy I like
won't talk to me at all because of that
tweet but [ __ ] it save the koalas is
that the girl that like put her nudes
out for Australia alright that's a big
peepee I'll take it
I have Mike know it's been three years
you don't need Teresa that's huge bebe
me and simple high school teacher
hearing my pupils talking about
PewDiePie oh oh it's a Swedish teacher
okay it's math related science 19 year
olds our teacher has big baby teacher
eyes big baby a huge dick that's
hilarious I love how this channel just
transcends time anyone can watch whether
you're 9 or 19 or 99 what do I am and
see what man is seeing big peepee
that rhyme so beautiful that I took me
way too long
Brazil only sends one person Iran my god
old god you're gonna be knocked over so
you know Iran just quit Iran just stops
being a country that's what happens me
knowing I'm not gonna get drafted into
World War three because I am a mom and
Peter pipe says I have big PP BAE BAE
BAE BAE baebae our records say that
you're a female but from an insider
source it says you have large peepee
what does that mean the code bro so
remember the code normal people in the
cpt pine nine tails when the cpt pie is
math related to science it's so funny
because it's so freaking through f to
all the poos that have been left alone
since I don't know what that is but big
BP announced that he will be taking a
break in January find support his
decision Felix well now I'm not doing it
I'm a god I I sucked through half of
January at least cuz then it just seems
like I I took a break because it was
January which is his lane because like I
could have just stopped in January but I
had nothing else to do really why am I
going on a break me watches peonies mom
is that pewdiepie me well yes but
actually no that's Papa's Moorea one of
the most beautiful women in the whole
world her eyes her beard her breath
through fantasy true love Instagram
deactivated account of the nude model
okay so he was her his best defender and
big peepee
can we talk about PT PI green-screen
himself into his own room huge PP well
site did this so that means
congratulations side it keep you
confirmed inside gets break too
you know I keep I keep going like oh
it's so hard and you break try that it's
almost every single video
that's a lot of work when you say war is
bad and get 5 million views all right
I'm not gonna take credit for preventing
World War 3 but I did say it and has
world 3 happened I don't think well 3
happen
I don't think world 3 happened wait I
Photoshop kids into my girlfriend poster
of a Kramer then printed it out to
replace the original coach peepee cute
cog players in Iran 360 no scope rocket
league players big peepee time flies
fast goddamn you guys have a cry
watching my videos a bunch of crybabies
yoga no Felix needs rest very much take
a break or draw 25 i already draw 25 but
i think i can say safely say uno and big
peepee home is where you don't smell
anything
that's buddy and that's a fact big
peepee that's a fact I totally forgot
that Gloria Borger was a real person
voice of concrete what oh my god Gloria
Borger actually made it all right there
Gloria boy he was in terrible now she's
working for CNN what the hell most
billionaires act reserved and with class
Elon Musk
it's the only way it's what God intended
there must be the mush Felix every
morning marcia where are my links oh my
god oh my god okay so I recently watched
ranked don't ask questions just follow
the story and there's a PewDiePie Easter
egg in Shrek and I can't believe no
one's talked about it there it is I
think I know it I know it they were in
Shrek all aligned
that's my origin story YouTube's 2020
try YouTube TV I have not gone that add
YouTube survey YouTube Music app YouTube
family plane try you to premium just try
it please do it's January and I'm not
again no way it doesn't matter I'm going
away nineteen-year-old
discovers planet six point nine times
larger than Earth on third day of
internship with NASA what that's fair
that's incredible huge news PP huge PP
so big and six point nine that's that's
an epic number two Felix are gonna be
going to World War three be like damn
that's so cool oh my god my aunt's hate
very nice very big P P a P to PI fan art
with watercolors because my computer
broken hey we got some happy wheels fan
art you know people treat me like God
how they ignore my existence unless they
need something from me oh I see Mitchell
Angelo was only 24 years old when he
completed the Pieta sculpture the fact
that he was a turtle makes it 10 times
more interesting
Mitchell Angelo was my favorite turd
Ninja Turtles after Raffaello and then
Leonardo and then I don't remember the
rest boner or peepee attack now I want
to learn piano I didn't know that's
crazy
Chris Hemsworth donates 1 million
dollars to Australian bushfire crisis
because that's what heroes do I hate how
people criticizing for it to like his
net worth its net worth it's not the
money in your bank account it's still an
amazing donation shut the [ __ ] up God
okay sorry it's big peepee energy I
can't get mad you can't get main pubes
okay I'm taking a break in January pee
actually in January Noah's notice it yet
I was surprised someone finally realized
I haven't actually gone into break tiny
penises were sign of intelligence in
ancient Greek times also Felix big brain
cute wait a minute wait a minute I was
interpreted as cuz yes they are small
peepee alright but it's more that you
can't control sex or peepee let's get
real here all right you got tiny peepee
not your fault I have ever don't have
that problem so can't relate but they're
always super muscular and super epic so
it's like well they worked on their body
that's what matters that's something you
became control think about that you're
small people sound boys I look like I'm
genuinely in pain people ear what is
this I'm infection people or anything in
about how she 2020 is going to be
forgetting that we will have an entire
month of 4/20 oh my god there better not
be some huge meme happening while I'm
gone okay that's gonna piss me off there
better not be some I don't know like
Logan Paul it's a dead body or some I
don't know you guys better not drag me
back it's what I'm saying menus love to
get sex women use sex to get love I use
a counterweight to launch 100 kilograms
stone projectiles over 300 meters yeah
this is it so the trebuchet that was
called the war wolf they started
building it outside a castle and the
people in the Casa saw it and were like
awful this should we surrender even
before they they completed building the
trebuchet that's how awesome trebuchet
czar the Scottish soldiers offered
surrender freeing the weapons potential
to destroy the entire castle Edward sent
the troops party back inside the castle
they claim you do not deserve any grace
but much surrender to my will
Edward decided to carry on with the
siege and witness the destruction power
of the weapon he was like you guys
surrendered but I kinda want to make
make it go boom boom he started hurling
three Boucher's are so awesome I love
the I love tribal chants they're like my
live war bad Trump backs away from
further military conflict with our reign
I'm not gonna take credit forward Pete
World Peace that would just be you know
ridiculous but I'm just
let the history books write themselves
you are welcome
oh my god it's true Boucher actually
becoming a meme that makes me so happy
only small people once Pokemon cut sword
shield trebuchet trebuchet I log
trebuchet all right big PP - right
that's good all right I got an ending
here I just wanted to say take this
moment to give a toast to my 9 year olds
thank you for watching across the years
I know I'm making this a bigger thing
than it is but it is weird for me too
it is a big thing even though it isn't a
big thing okay so just I want to say
thank you for watching my videos it
makes me happy that you watch it because
I like making it so cheers to you one
thing I really realize is like I love
making videos and I love interacting
with you guys it's really fun but I
think this year has just been so much
piling up that I think I'm like okay I
should probably just like cool down for
a bit and then we'll come back with
10,000% we'll come back with a fire
power of a million trebuchet that's it
for me see you guys I don't know when
I'll be back but have a good time like
just like enjoy yourself I was gonna
shout out a bunch of all the channels to
watch but I that I'm not doing that
again and that's it
hey door hey door hey